today marks the 50th anniversary of the
ibrox disaster
66 football fans perished as the result
of a crush
at stairway 13. a solemn act of
remembrance
in an empty stadium the old firm rivalry
is a bitter one
and deep rooted but it's always been put
aside to remember the 66 lives that were
lost here at ibrox
50 years ago the current rangers manager
stephen gerrard lost his cousin at
hillsborough so
understands better than most the
significance of the anniversary
because of the call with 19 things will
look slightly different
but you know as a club we still want to
pay our full respect to everyone that
was involved
um and so all the names that are no
longer with us
certainly know what this
disaster means to people and obviously
want to send my full respect to
all the families and the survivors and
also pay my respects to the people that
passed
65 men and boys 30 of them just
teenagers and one
18 year old girl died in the crush on
stairway 13
at ibrox 200 more were injured
the sum of the 80 000 fans began to
leave the ground following a 90th minute
celtic goal
that thought someone fell causing a
pileup of bodies that in places was six
deep the survivors some of whom tried to
help the rescue efforts
were left in a state of shock before you
knew it
because of the volume of pressure on
your body
you know you couldn't show you the air
was getting squeezed out your lungs
and they you know that you felt as if
everything was going to pack in you and
you couldn't shout
my legs were wrapped around a boy behind
me and i was looking off my arm
was still in a position where i could
move them
and at one stage i thought that was it
that i was gone and they
actually prayed i said please god don't
let me die
the club had planned to mark today's
anniversary with a fitting commemoration
but kovid restrictions forbid it a few
socially distanced supporters
the only ones able to pay their respects
ranges one
celtic nil unlike the old firm clash of
50 years ago
today's ended in a win for rangers but
for many today is not about goals
points or bragging rights it's about
remembering 66 people
who came here to enjoy a game of
football but who never came home
fraser moored sky news